let's go back to the phones a lot of
people holding today big big news week
let's see what people have to say at 6 1
7 8 3 0 47 50 our next caller is from
the 845 area code 845 who's this hey
it's mark Benjamin go ahead mark yeah I
was just wondering what are your
thoughts on the people in the
cryptocurrency community have like a
kind of a pseudo myth of the Fed and I
want to just ask what do you think is
real and what do you think is overblown
on that and what's possible what are you
doing boy it sounds like it's getting a
little crazy there are lots of people
talking hear me yeah what Big E and what
do you thought thoughts on the new belt
and road initiative and do you think
it's gonna kneecap the dog don't know a
thing about the Balkan Road initiative
what specific conspiracy about the Fed
are you referring to like the one that
it's all secretly controlled by a Jewish
cabal or something a little more
palatable rather than a Jew well unlike
unlike the normal conservatives it's
more like or I guess the more racial of
types of conservatives is just basically
like the Fed is controlled but is not a
not a state property or basically is not
controlled by America and also like the
other feds around the world is it can
available either being controlled by a
small group not just what's called not
just the what's called it may be someone
happens to be Jewish but some others
basically just very rich guys that
doesn't have the best interest at heart
where for the majority of people that's
that if I wanted to boil it down and
that's also kind of the crypto the
silver and all that stuff community
that's us that like we want to back it
by stuff but at the same time they'll
cause some serious problems what's the
specific as specifically as possible
mark what is the specific question here
okay
what is um is the is the Fed like is
having the Fed not in Fed being
controlled by the state that the feds in
a problem and this is a debate is in
state or state is in country like nation
state mm just the there's a cut like you
know the you ask the England's and just
you know England and you kind of make it
like the banking system a bit more
simple to make it so that people can not
have it inflated and a bunch of guys get
away scot-free for inflating the
currency or nation or is it about Jews I
don't know mark I'm doing the best I can
sorry sorry it's like the cryptocurrency
community basically it's basically like
oh yeah I forgot that it's always and
I'm really in our control that's
basically it okay I'll look into that
I'm not I'm not really sure I'm not
really sure I I don't know I I think I'm
in over it this is above my paygrade I
don't know what else to say